introducing this year's Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit cover model
Martha oh Stuart Martha Stewart looking
fire on the cover of Sports Illustrated
that's definitely a thirst trap the
lifestyle experts stopped by the Today
Show on Monday morning for the big
reveal to be on the cover at my age was
uh was a challenge
and uh and I I think I met the challenge
Martha who is 81 years old shared the
secret sauce to keeping it hot for me it
is a testament to good living and I
think that all of us should think about
good living successful living and not
about aging the whole aging thing is so
boring it was a big Challenge and I like
challenges as you can imagine Martha
says the mag asked her to be the
Covergirl back in November and by
January she was posing on the beach in
her swimsuit I didn't starve myself but
I didn't eat any bread or pasta for a
couple months I went to Pilates every
other day I live a clean life anyway
pretty you know good diet and good
exercising and healthy skin care and all
of that stuff but it was kind of fun all
that Echoes what the TV icon told E.T
back in 2020. just eat well exercise
well Garden
climb mountains I find Kilimanjaro for
goodness sake I went up into the
Himalayas you have to do that kind of
stuff that's the kind of stuff that
keeps one vibrant and young and uh it's
important and Martha says she hopes her
SI debut inspires others to live their
best lives I hope it does give people
women especially an opportunity to
revisit their lives and and get with the
picture of course this is hardly the
first time she's made headlines for
being a mega babe we're going backwards
now the clock has been turned backwards
back in January she shared this
filter-free selfie from the salon
writing in the caption that there was
absolutely no re-imaging and back in
2020 Martha taught a master class in
thirst trapping when she posted this
sultry pool Pig I just thought I looked
great coming out of the pool I looked so
nice the sun was on my face and I
thought oh that looks pretty so I took
the picture and it was pretty it looked
good as for Sports Illustrated Martha is
one of four cover models Kim Petrus
Brooks Nader and Megan Fox also pose for
the Annual issue which hits newsstands
May 18th as for Martha she reminds her
fans it's a good thing to shake it up
and you're through changing her through
that's one of my mottos you know that
when you're through changing your throat
that's right and so change is very good
um evolution is very good on just trying
new things being Fearless is very good
uh it's uh Don't Be Afraid Don't Be
Afraid of Anything
[Music]
thank you